c'est aussi un grand moment que je vous
propose maintenant régulièrement
découvre ses sélections livre ensemble
pour nos enfants le premier tour des
élections municipales c'est bientôt
assassin ce week end à vivre évidemment
sur france 3 tv sur les écrans connectés
et sur france 3 avec des débats en
régions et tout le reste
traditionnellement de nombreux bureaux
de vote sont installés dans les écoles
prime c'est que les enfants s'interroge
pas seulement sur la sexualité dont on
vient de parler du javari mais aussi sur
ce qu'est une élection et notamment un
maire est là typhaine failli faire
arrive vous avez la solution pour nous
super oui parce que parfois c'est
difficile de leur expliquer pourquoi on
vote à quoi ça sert ce qu'est une
élection alors pour les tout petits à
partir de 3 ans j'ai un livre super qui
s'apprête à sortir ça s'appelle voter le
loup de davide cali et maïali clavelée
c'est publié chez casterman
alors l'histoire est très simple il ya
une élection à la ferme est alors comme
d'habitude il ya toujours les mêmes
candidats
c'est simple il ya cochons poules et
sourire mais tout d'un coup il ya un
nouveau candidat qui a paraît il
s'appelle pascal le loup alors il est
séduisant
il a dû morella ducharme normale avec un
prénom comme ça il s'appelle pas ce 15
mai oui pascal et en plus il se veut
rassembleur évidemment puisqu'il est un
peu inter-espèces points au dessus de ça
voilà ce livre va permettre d'expliquer
aux enfants tout le déroulé d'une
campagne électorale à la fois le collage
d'affichés à propagande électorale le
vote et même l'élan les lendemains qui
déchantent passe avec ces mobilisations
citoyennes vous voyez donc c'est
vraiment un livre que j'ai adoré c'est
un vrai coup de coeur parce que ça
permet d'expliquer cela aux enfants dès
3 ans donc ça va vous sauver à la
maternelle de ce super et tout ça tire
dans un tout petit album ça c'est assez
surprenant et ça bon génial vous en avez
un autre je crois plus didactique celui
ci il va aux enfants à partir de 6 ans
oui voilà ça s'appelle je vote je
choisis ces deux marques sous le même et
serge bloch et c'est chez seuil jeunesse
alors sa part d'un constat simple quand
on est enfant eh bien il faut faire des
choix toute la journée
est-ce qu'on mangerait plus tôt une
glace ou un gâteau est ce qu'on va
utiliser des feutres ou des crayons de
couleur et bien si vous partez de ce
constat simple vous pouvez expliquer une
élection le héros du livre va commencer
par essayer de convaincre ses camarades
de les rallier à une de ses idées et
puis après le livre a et vous
pour expliquer que c'est le principe de
toute élection et elle va permettre
d'expliquer et bien tous les candidats
les campagnes le vote et même les
procédures très simples qui sont en mise
en place quoi s'est expliqué avec des
illustrations
voilà une illustration très amusante et
puis surtout des exemples très concrets
ce soit on imaginer qu'il faille choisir
ma un animal par exemple dans une classe
et bien il va falloir voter
donc comme on organise une élection
qu'est ce que c'est que la démocratie
alors c'est vraiment sympa pour les
enfants entre 6 et 8 ans va dire non
alors pour monter un petit peu dans les
âges pour entrer davantage dans le
détail finalement du processus électoral
sur la par exemple la fonction de maire
les rouages des élections et là c'est
plutôt on va dire un ouvrage
documentaire at il fait oui alors ça
s'appelle les élections c'est de sylvie
payet et beaussier pardon et mode rimane
c'est chez nathan alors ils ont une
super collection qui s'appelle questions
réponses c'est à partir de 7 ans et là
ça répond à une trentaine de questions
alors je sais pas même des questions que
vous pouvez vous poser
faut-il réfléchir avant de voter
pourquoi certains électeurs
s'abstiennent t-il c'est quoi la
politique et qui finance une campagne
alors toutes ces questions vont trouver
des réponses assez courte et il ya aussi
deux pages sur le mandat de maire alors
c'est assez intéressant puisque c'est ce
qui ce qui est en cause là
dimanche prochain c'est vraiment une
mine d'informations je le conseille pour
les élémentaires
alors il ya juste un petit bémol à la
fin il ya quelques pages sur l'europe
l'union européenne alors il faudra quand
même expliqué que le bric site est passé
parce que l'ouvragé aura quelques années
mais
c'est très sympathique très bien ça
s'appelle les élections qualité de
sylvie bourcier et mode rien man peut
être très précis je précise aussi qu'en
vous mettra tout sur internet dcm
quelques millions à la fin de cette
émission
évidemment on s'intéresse aussi aux
collégiens là vous avez une bd à me
suggérer intitulé la démocratie en bd
c'est quoi cette bd est bien c'est
encore plus large cette fois puisque ça
s'adresse aux collégiens ça a été écrit
par nathalie l'oiseau qui est députée
européenne mais qui est aussi l'ancienne
directrice de l'ena et dessiné par acti
on chez casterman
alors sa part aussi d'un exemple très
concret l'élection des délégués de
classe en sixième max et nadia voudrait
se présenter mais qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une élection comment faire campagne
qu'est ce que c'est que la démocratie
ils vont mener l enquête à partir
d'exemples très simples qui sont autour
d'eux pourquoi y at il des
manifestations d'agriculteurs
comment gérer une inondation pourquoi
leurs parents sont ils toujours
mécontents de leurs élus donc ça parle
d'exemples très concrets et on va
pourtant dans le détail vraiment dans le
détail du code électoral de la
constitution qui a droit de vote
pourquoi comment la séparation même des
pouvoirs c'est vraiment assez dense mais
je le conseille aux collégiens et même à
leurs parents qui auraient peut-être
oublié certaines notions et puis je vous
rappelle que la démocratie c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
pour le peuple
et oui c'est ça faut pas l'oublier et on
vote évidemment ce week-end aura
l'occasion d'en reparler je le redis à
vivre sur les écrans connectés et sur
france3 forcément